i don't know what's going on wait are
they killing them what's up backstreet
boys
you come back to your point i wasn't
ready for this hard it's too hard
hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
i am excited
because apple has finally added some
great games
to their apple arcade subscription and
in fact
there was one game that finally got me
to resubscribe
so as you can see right here apple's
added some new games so what i'm going
to be doing in this video is i'm going
to be playing
the top new games that were just
released for apple arcade
as well as some of the ones that i
haven't played since i haven't really
played in over a year and a half since
the last time i made a video on this so
let's get right into it first off i want
to quickly show you guys some of the
plus games that they added
for example cut the rope plus of course
this is a simple game you just swipe to
cut the rope
and boom but now let's get into the fun
new games and i definitely want to start
out with
nba 2k21 and look at that we have online
matchmaking with
real people that is what makes a good
game
decent graphics for a mobile game so far
all right
how do you play this game what
i don't know how to play this bro this
sucks dude yo stop him stop me he's
trying to go
i don't know i should have done the
tutorial man
i don't know what's going on pass it
pass it bro oh oh
he almost got it the fight oh
it counts does it count i think that
counted all right way up there way up
there whoop
boom oh what oh wait does that
count oh yeah i got it all right i'm
catching up oh stop him
dude why don't you stop him let's go
throw it
whoa oh what jump jump
what yeah basketball is not for me i get
out of this game
whatever wonder box is the next game
this is supposed to be like some kind of
a
zelda slash minecraft thing oh we got a
bad dude
what's up all right this is cool
there you go dude how do you even get
past these guys
sweet all right finally got something
right here
sick all right guys to be honest i don't
know if i'm feeling this game
let's play something else all right here
is another game w-o-d
begin skirmish let's go whoa okay this
is
actually kind of cool very interesting
graphics in this game
oh it's two dudes whoa
that was cool this is crazy i'm just
mashing the buttons at this point man
let's try this out oh
combo attack this is actually kind of
fun man this is like a
pretty fun rpg style game oh this is a
cat
who made this game
right if i die here if i die
oh i think i'm dead yeah hey it's
actually kind of difficult too
next up song pop party play with real
people right away i'll just choose this
guy nate this guy's bumping
[Music]
britney spears new kids on the block
dude is randy's fingers man
don't speak of course man don't speak
got that
yeah you guys all got it wrong okay
yeah not bad it's cool that you're
playing with real
people so you're basically just guessing
music
but i am first all right let's do this
again i don't need the controller
actually makes it harder
90s rap mama said knock you out they
literally just said the name
tupac of course honestly i don't know
yeah i lost all right let's try it again
one more time whitney
of course backstreet boys you come back
to dude
what's that person doing barbie girl
warren g nate dog all right i lost again
all right next up this is the one game
that made me
get apple arcade again and that is
the new fantasian created by
the creators of final fantasy which i
love
it's like we've got some kind of final
fantasy style cinematic here so you have
your turns right here so it's his turn
right here
so can i hit both of them boom just like
that this is totally giving me
final fantasy nostalgia all right let's
do the same thing
hit both of these guys just barely boom
the only thing i don't like about this
so far is that the battles have been
very repetitive
like these three little robot dudes over
and over for a couple times now
analyze okay so i've got to do what
lightning damage to it
oh we just got wrecked
it's kind of cool they're introducing
stuff like on the side
just like what we had in final fantasy
10 so that's kind of cool
wait are they healing them they're
repairing that robot
we got this oh critical nice keep
smacking this dude
come on there you go
finally so far i don't know much in
terms of the story i wish they kind of
gave you more
said his name is sid of course
from final fantasy
oh there you go secret room
unfortunately i can't keep playing this
game all day but so far it's been pretty
fun i just wish there was a little bit
more variety with the
combat system but i'm definitely gonna
have to keep playing this a little bit
later
and check it out but now let's move on
to the next one taiko
pop tap bandai namco that is classic
that's like
arcade style all right this is weird man
okay what's going on
tycho all right all right guys this is
weird
what is going on
[Music]
what
oh okay okay i can see how this would be
fun
later when it becomes very hard yeah
i'm sure when this gets to like more
difficult levels it's actually going to
be
pretty difficult and that that is what's
going to make it fun
all right let's go out loud we're going
hard let's do this
we're going straight to the hard that's
going to be tough
oh it's going fast all right we got this
hard bro i wasn't ready for this i
wasn't ready
i'm just like smashing all the buttons
man ah
hard it's too hard all right this is
crazy this is crazy all right i'm gonna
do normal let's do normal we got this
yeah i'm so focused guys so focused on
this game
three four five six seven this is
actually kind of fun drum roll let's go
hey not bad extraordinary what's up
let's move on to the next one
all right i want to try the star trek
one is this turn base 2
it is turn based uh let's kill this dude
nice all right this is it's kind of
repetitive dude we're on like the same
area
i don't know how i feel about this yet
come on man just let me skip all this
stuff let's go
one hp what
sorry guys i can't do this not this game
i don't like it i don't like
clap golf let's try
that one out that's a new one i think
this looks like it's gonna be cool let's
try this
wait what did i actually do something oh
no it's in the sand
there you go there you go
oh too hard there you go
okay i got it all right watch this watch
this boom
oh it landed like nowhere
[Music]
hey not bad not bad i tried now we got
to get it over
oh it's not where i wanted
hey it's close all right we got this
hey ah come on dude it's like literally
right here
got it boom
check this out there you go all right
guys that was fun this is not my game
though
skate city skateboarding game let's try
this
woo flick left stick dude ollie oh okay
i got this
flick right stick up to do a holly nolly
what oh
i'm good at this bro just like that
let's go oh this is actually fun man
oh
nice next one towers
of everland this is kind of like a
skyrim rpg
the controls are so bad
oh these controls are horrible yeah this
game sucks
dude what is this yeah not this game
alright so there you guys go i just
spent a bunch of time
playing the latest games that were just
added to apple arcade to answer the
original question
is apple arcade worth it in 2021
honestly it's still not most of those
games are just
too casual for me i just can't see
myself
playing them they're missing one big
thing and that is having
really good online multiplayer along
with a really good
ranking system i want a ranking system
so i can compare myself
and my skills to other players and
that's what makes me want to play games
so based on that i'd say that the best
two games that i played
were fantasion first of all i just wish
it got more into the storyline
and that song pop party which was
actually kind of fun and addictive but i
can see how
it's not going to last very long you
know you're going to get kind of bored
of it
and the taiko pop tap was actually
pretty fun as well
so i don't know i don't think it's
enough to make apple arcade worth five
dollars in 2021
so i don't know let me know what you
guys think down below
but i think we're gonna need more and
more games and more fun games to
actually make it worth it so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did go ahead and click the circle about
to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you
in the next video